was soll die scheiße an mein lieblings
tv sender rtl 2 ist ja bekannt für seine
wissens reichen serien wie
beispielsweise love island berlin tag &
nacht oder auch köln 50667 doch nun habe
ich in den trends eine video entdeckt
und bin einfach mal auf den kanal
gegangen weil ich dachte hey was ist das
für ein kanal ms ist der kanal hilf mir
junge pleite verzweifelt
150 tausend abonnenten habe ich mich
erst mal gefragt von welchem sender ist
dass rtl2 ja
von wem auch sonst doch ich wusste bis
zu dem zeitpunkt wirklich noch immer
nicht was in der serie hilft mir jonk
leit und verzweifelt wirklich passiert
deswegen habe ich einfach mal bei
wikipedia nachgeschaut svenja finanziert
sich durch bafög und einen nebenjob ihr
studium und lebt in einer wg als ihre
mitbewohnerin aussieht um ins ausland zu
gehen sucht sie sich eine zwischen
mieterin leider stellt sich lee nach
kurzer zeit als fehlgriff heraus sie
zahlt die miete nicht und bedient sich
rücksichtslos an sven ihres
lebensmitteln es geht also darum dass
dort ein mädchen ist und ihre freundin
des ausgezogen und dann hat sie sich
eine zwischen mieterin gesucht die sich
aber bei ihr bedient und ihr dinge cloud
da wird man normalerweise denken hey das
kann man vielleicht in ein 2 3 folgen
abdrehen 470 episoden wir haben also
einiges auch dass wir reagieren müssen
das lustige war tatsächlich auch das
bild was bei wikipedia für die serie
genutzt wurde um die seele sag ich mal
zu beschreiben weil es sich irgendwie
ein logo oder irgendwie sowas sondern
dass hier eine frau die eine andere frau
dabei anguckt wie sie von ihrem freund
betitelt wird
da ja genau das hier ist auf jeden fall
mal von hilfe jung pleite und
verzweifelt wir sehen auch schon bei
ähnliche kanäle teilen des jugend sieht
man ganz genau was hier hochgeladen wird
auf jeden fall können wir einfach mal
hier auf videos klicken und dann
sortieren wir die videos mal nach dem
beliebtesten da sehen wir schon das
meist geklickte video 3,7 millionen
aufrufe finde ich auch stark nur 80 69
80 prozent nur 73 likes haben uns mal
ein paar titel an nachhilfe mal anders
schüler verführt lehrerin
dass mein sohn 35 glaubt er wäre ein
sechsjähriges mädchen
lin das baby ist nur eine plastikpuppe
kann man muss ich das irgendwie
verstehen mein freund messe mich
es macht überhaupt keinen sinn was auf
diesem kanal hochgeladen wird meine
damen und herren allerdings habe ich mir
gedacht da wir hier so unzählige videos
haben suche ich mir einfach mal eins
raus reagiere da heute drauf
wir nehmen einfach mal dieses video mein
sohn 35 glaubt er wäre ein sechsjähriges
mädchen
wir sehen schon was hier vorne abgeht
wir schauen uns jedoch erstmal ein paar
kommentare der zuschauer an nach dieser
folge muss sich zum psychologen youtube
geöffnet video gesehen youtube
geschlossenen therapeuten gesucht ich
glaube der redaktionen gehen die ideen
aus das nächste meinen opa denkt er ist
ein pinguin die hat der kameramann das
ausgehalten ich hätte mich totgelacht
also man sich direkt was hier angeblich
in dieser folge abgeben soll
man soll angeblich viel lachen und jeder
fragt sich hey was ist das für eine
scheiße ich brauche die kaputten wir
befinden uns jetzt hier allerdings auch
beim video meine damen und herren
bevor ich jetzt allerdings auf play
drücken möchte ich direkt sagen wenn ich
mich über eine person kaputt lache oder
sage was das soll oder was die mission
von dieser person ist oder was für ein
allgemeines die hochgeladen wird ich
möchte vorher noch mal eben kurz
klarstellen dass ich mich nicht über die
echten personen hinter den schauspielern
sage ich mal lustig mache ich möchte
niemanden in seiner würde verletzen oder
fertig machen oder sonst was ich
reagiere nur auf die gespielte person in
dieser serie namens hilft mir
und das tue ich jetzt auch zeit
aufzustehen kopie weil wir die mutter
kommt rein und weckt ihre tochter sasha
hat etwas mitgebracht erdbeermilch
[Musik]
a
natürlich habe ich dir noch versprochen
sorry
vorletzter ganz kurze real-tor das kann
man doch nicht wirklich einer sagen dass
das echt ist ich glaube wir sind uns
alle einig dass das einfach irgendwelche
leute sind die von rtl2 bezahlt werden
wo gesagt mit hey wollt ihr euch im
schlaf machen nicht wir geben euch zehn
euro und die sagen dann halt auch noch
ja
also man muss rtl 2 sagen das ist ein
krasses konzept die machen da irgendwie
scheiße und alle im internet lassen sich
darüber lustig und dadurch gibt es
natürlich dann 2,4 millionen aufrufe in
nicht mal zwei monaten
wir schauen mal dieses meisterwerk des
films an
[Musik]
jetzt zur kirche und war mit dem
frühstück auf dich okay sie wartet mit
einem frühstück auf ihn
er zieht sich jetzt um exakt
abendkleidern sich ach du scheiße
was ist denn mit ihr es was ist mit dem
den bedienen
ok jetzt kommt ein typ an die mit der
finsternis unfall oder mehr rechte
siegfried wenn es wenigstens gut
gespielt werden auch ok aber was
kann ich mir auch mal mitspielen
berichtet luftbilder so hätten zwei kann
ich mal ganz auftritt haben
warum holen
rüdiger hat sich in eine traumwelt ach
du scheiße jetzt kommen noch so
möchtegern therapeuten da an und sagen
was hier abgeht das hat er mich ein ganz
ja wo es immer diese top fünf besten tv
fans gab
oder sie halt allein schon tv fail ist
die mutter fördert sein verhalten und
das ist weder alters noch
geschlechtstypische es wundert mich also
nicht dass die beiden abgelehnt und
ausgegrenzt werden ja doch volker wird
wahrscheinlich pop doch noch zu sammeln
er heißt auch mit lebte hat er namens du
scheiße das ist das ding ist halt auch
erstmal die bin ganz ehrlich diese frau
hier sieht vielleicht aus als wäre die
50 55 sagen wir mal 55 höchsten ist er
hier ist 35 diesem 20 jahre will ich
sagen allerhöchstens auseinander
seit sie müsste ihnen mit 20 jahren
bekommen haben was okay ist aber sehr
früh ich glaube aber wir wissen alle
dass er nicht verwandt sind
wenn nur einfach wieder hinfällt stehst
du auf und riecht ist ein krönchen
aber ich habe dem einen
kommentarschreiber wirklich recht wie
konnte da einen kameramann neben stehen
und das film und sich denken hey das ist
mein traumberuf darauf das wollte ich
schon immer mal film und ich breche
gerade nicht in lachen aus doch der
nächste hack lässt nicht lange auf sich
warten
der nächste schock die 35 jährige
rüdiger mädchen
ein ice ist rüdiger heim gekommen
das hat vieles mehr sehen sie da ist der
episode also mal schauen ob rüdiger sein
so ein scheißdreck science bekommt auch
die mutter sagt ja ich bin ein sehr
ruhiger kommt an meine tochter so zu
erschrecken
rüdiger ist okay warte
wir warten nicht ich habe keine ahnung
mehr was soll überhaupt adaptiert
rüdiger ist nicht pädophil
er hat einfach einen wichtigen
entwicklungsschritt noch nicht gemacht
darüber was die ursachen für sein
verhalten sind kann ich nur spekulieren
danke über diese professionelle
stellungnahme frau therapeuten ja der
rüdiger der ist nicht pädophil
aber was er genau hat das weiß ich jetzt
auch nicht darüber kann ich nur
spekulieren
also ich würde sagen ich bin arzt und
als dann jemand ankommen und sagt etwas
am knie dann sage ich einfach ja ich
glaube sie haben schmerzen im knie aber
was heißt genau ist da kann ich nur
spekulieren woher kommst du wegen mordes
sieht so aus als hätten sie
kopfschmerzen fast genau dagegen tun
können da kann nicht wirklich nur
spekulieren die ihre bremsen vom auto
sind kaputt war das sieht so aus als
könnten sie nicht mehr bremsen aber was
das genau wer vor gerufen hat darüber
kann ich nur spekulieren ob man in
diesem video hier von luca einen daumen
hoch geben sollte so dass er noch mal
auf diese scheiße reagiert dass darüber
kann ich nur spekulieren sollte man aber
machen denn wir haben noch 469 episoden
vor uns ich meine tochter noch einmal
anfassen
dann werde ich die anzeigen kinder
belästigung der entwicklung von einem 5
mein gott wir haben einen therapeuten
befürchtet dass steffi diese realität
bislang einfach nicht wahrhaben möchte
mal ganz kurz
ich nehme diese wahl auf vezzali dabei
sieht so aus wie rüdiger ich möchte
sagen wir ein hausrecht gebrauch ich
werde ihnen nichts mehr verkaufen sie
kann ich mitprägen milliarden mal was
ich auch sehr stark findet dieses
kennzeichen lizenziert aber dass wir
hinten das er gebnis heimweg drauf
rüdiger will jetzt hier irgendeinen
typen um abend den er getroffen hat
es gibt der hunde bank greife doch der
mutter kommt an und rüdigers auftreten
wirkt auf außenstehende stark
irritierend
all diese therapeuten wie krank ist und
35 jähriger der sich als sechsjähriges
mädchen aus gibt und die therapeutin
sagt dann im fernsehen rüdigers
auftreten liegt auf auf zustimmende
stark irritierend danke das hätte nicht
auch jeder andere mensch gesehen
motto ich weiß wirklich bewusst was
heute sind noch dabei in bombay hinken
und jetzt wird warum mein gott ach du
scheiße der vater hat angst um seinen
sohn alter dieser scheiß therapeuten
rtl2 kann man eben eine petition machen
dass ihr euch da richtige therapeuten
sucht nicht nur für die leute in der
serie sondern auch für ein paar die sich
diese serie ausgedacht haben
wie kann sich rtl2 den denken hey wir
sind ein professionelles unternehmen so
was packen wir ins fernsehen sorry aber
das ist in meinen augen menschenrechte
sind ziemlich abstoßend an der stelle
mich das heutige video ist allerdings
auch band meine damen und herren wenn
euch meine reaktion auf die serie er
hilft mir was sich in den trends
entdeckt habe gefallen hat das gerne mal
einen like das soll ich eventuell
nochmal auf eine folge von hilfen mehr
reagieren könnt ihr mir gerne folgen die
kommentare schreiben
dann überlege ich mir ob mein herz und
mein gehirn das noch mitmachen denkt
noch mal dass ich wirklich nicht
irgendetwas gegen diese leute hier sagen
möchte die diese personen spielen
sondern wirklich ist es geht hier
wirklich nur um diese gespielte serie um
diese figur sage ich mal in dieser folge
also ich habe nichts persönlich gegen
den rüdiger der vielleicht in echt fritz
heißt und 40 jahre alt ist und
vielleicht ist ja auch wirklich ein
sechsjähriges mädchen
[Musik]